looking to snap that
17-game losing streak and their d-back
starting pitcher in game one the
right-hander merrill
kelly 14 starts this year coming off the
loss at san francisco last wednesday
and he smacks one deep into right field
and that is
off the rule colton wong on his way to
second and the hot back continues
for the brewers second baseman out
number two and on the play juan took
third two down
here's avi garcia and garcia
weiner on the left center field at base
hit and once again the brewers get on
the board in the opening inning
rbi knock for garcia as wong will score
it's amazing how many times the opponent
has scored first against the
diamondbacks
as of late last 46 games now the
opponent has scored first in 35 games
third base runner in the first for
milwaukee that brings up the shortstop
williams that's strike three caught got
him looking
so kelly ends up with a strikeout we
have played a half inning
the lefty brett anderson yeah he's two
and four
he's looking for his first win since mid
april one out nobody on
and that'll bring up rojas and rojas is
out number two
two up two down upstairs with 90 miles
an hour but that was
way upstairs he got him to chase two up
two down down cabrera ground ball to
short adamus backs up
fields plenty of time accurate throw to
first they get cabrera
and one two three go the d backs in the
first stenny we'll go to the second lead
off single to start the second inning by
louis cerius
jackie bradley jr there's another
breaking ball and that's the second
strikeout for merrell kelly
and no reason to throw him a fastball
door breaking ball that time bradley way
underneath that pitch for strike three
pitcher down brett anderson and he's
gonna swing and he chops it to short
this should be two
out of sinking and out at first double
play
so he did but he didn't get it over the
head of cabrera instead he hit it to
ahmed
hi brett anderson had a really easy
first
inning 12 pitches christian walker
starts off the second with a base hit
tied one at first nobody out and here's
josh reddick
[Applause]
and he knocks it into right center
walker's on the move
christian's in it third d-max have
something quicker to start the second
there's paving smith there's the base
head we're tied up
three straight singles open up the
second against anderson
that's what payman was doing so well in
the early part of the season if he did
get to a two-strike count he was
more than willing to go the other way if
the pitcher worked in the way
big hole on that left side of the
infield and david drives home the first
d-backs run of the game
great start three consecutive singles
ahead of nick ahmed
knocks that into right field they'll
stop redick at third they're loaded
make it four consecutive singles to
start the second
oak comes in hitting 2-14 but he's got
14 runs padded end of the year
that one's through as well riddick is
home
here comes pavon here's the throw
got him avisael garcia in right
touchdown pavon smith diamondbacks get
one
and they take a 2-1 lead lisa garcia
charging hard fields within real
shallow right field a perfect two-hop
throw to the plate that time and narvaez
hanging in there
[Music]
and i think they're going to take a look
at let's take a look at
brett anderson and scott barringer the
athletic trainer
this isn't good wow okay gonna do it all
right done
let's see he just started right there
maybe leg
and then the fun begins trying to get
out of the way on the throw from garcia
from right field
we're told brett anderson's injury was
right knee discomfort now it's going to
be right-handed trevor richards in out
of the bullpen
and they're loaded for martay base hit
ahmed is home they'll stop stephen bowe
not going to run on garcia
twice in the same inning and it's three
to one and the bases are still full boy
could tell marta really heating up he's
hit safely now in sixth grade
cabrera digs into the plate 3-2 on the
way
and that is strike three called yep
change up gets the job done for trevor
richard so he minimizes the damage
3-1 merrill kelly has retired the last
five he's faced and now of isaiah garcia
this is hammered right at cattell martay
yes he got it a sliding grab by cattell
in right center takes the base it away
from garcia
out number two two up two down
[Applause]
to shortstop nick ahmed got a hurry
well kelly works a one two three fourth
he sat down eight straight and holds a
three to one lead
first and third with one man out now for
rojas
josh punches that by it is home to make
it four to one
and martay's on the move they're gonna
stop him at third
it's an rbi double for joshua
that looks so easy when josh lets that
ball get deep like this and then
slice it the other direction there's
this durable cabrera
first pitch grounded too short booted by
adamas
a run will score they'll get the out at
first and on the play
getting into third bases rojas it's 5-1
d-backs
boy that wasn't going to be an easy play
and it looked like it was going to be an
easy out
but adamus moved to the baseball jackie
bradley jr strikeout victim his first
time the center fielder
jackie bradley jr rips one into right
field to the corner and that's extra
bases
jbj on his way to second with a one-out
double two outs of the inning now
there's wong first one to him is skyed
in the left
and out there is baby smith he's under
he's got it
side retired no runs a double the man
left brewers have now left two on the
night
thomas got his second hit a two out
single to get vote to the plate
goes pitch is taking the throw nailed
him at second
omar narvaez catches nick on there
omar narvaez showing off the arm
and he cuts down nick ahmed trying to
steal here in the fifth
harrell has set down 12 of the last 13
batters he's faced full count on
christian yelich
got him yeah trying out number four two
ounces in the sixth
so that's a good pitch to a left-handed
hitter from a right-handed pitcher if
you put it in that spot
you sailed garcia had a two-out single
in the first made it one-nothing
milwaukee and merrell has barely been
touched since
ground ball the first nice play walker
smothers the ball gets up and slips on
the bag
things going well for the d-backs here
as we go to the bottom of the sixth
inning
and making his major league debut is
right-hander jake cousins
he is the cousin of minnesota vikings
quarterback kirk cousins
three and two the count to vote cousins
delivers
he struck him out there you go look at
the bender little slider for strikeout
number one there you go
it was all two seamers yeah mid-90s
and went with the breaking ball if her
cousin ends up as a strikeout
that's slider boy that council's saying
it's been better
and he's not kidding back to that case
this first of the night he's on with one
out now for arias
holds it first called strike three knew
it
got caught looking at a fastball 94
from merrill kelly two outs in the
seventh now jackie bradley jr
hits it hard but right at rojas
merrill kelly through seven we'll go to
the night three outs away from
snapping a franchise record 17-game
losing streak the last team to lose 18
games in a row was the 2005
kansas city royals and he slams one to
left center
there's paving smith and that'll bring
up omar narvaez the catcher
is grounded going to be a tough play
ahmed is going to have to make it from
the right side of the infield throws
and he got him at first round number two
two outs in the ninth
in the air to center ketel marten is
under it
and the 17-game losing streak ends right
here
d-backs win it it's been a while since
we've seen
smiles in the dugout at the end of the
ball game this has to feel like the
weight of the world has been lifted off
the diamondback shoulder